ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
ครัวรออะไรคะหัวเราะตัวเองค่ะตกใจวีดีโอ
อัดแล้ว
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะนัดเรียนตอนดีค่ะนักเรียน
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงขอแชร์ไวท์บอร์ดใช่ไหมเขียน
วันที่ได้ค่ะอ้าวมันไม่ขึ้นเหรอครับผู้
หญิงกูอะแชร์ก็ได้นะคะโอเคได้ค่ะได้ค่ะกู
เองเดิมนะคะเนี่ยกูเอกคุยแชร์ให้ผู้หญิง
เราสักครู่ตายค่ะครูหญิงรอครูเอ๋ได้ค่ะ
โอเค
มาไหมยัง
มาแล้วค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเอาเองเขียนตรงไหนได้ผู้หญิงต้อง
บอกนะคะลูกและเขียนได้หมดเลยค่ะกูเองอ่ะ
อารายทั้งหมดสีขาวเลยค่ะแต่ว่ามันครูอาจ
จะต้องซูมนิดหน่อยอ่ะเพราะว่ามันเห็นทั้ง
หมดของคู๋เลยนะอ๋ออาจจะต้องปิดปิดตรง
Format  background ตรงนี้ค่ะ
ตรงไหนเอ่ยตรงขวามือของครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมคะ
Format  background แล้วมันมีมันเปิด
อยู่อ่ะ solid ฟิวขวามือครูเอ๋โอเคเป็น
อีกห้ามันอาจจะ Way เขียนใหญ่ๆได้เลยนะคะ
เพราะรูปมันไม่ได้ใหญ่มากถ้าโอเคโอเคขยาย
ก่อนเปิด
ฝากตาอย่างนั้นแหละได้เปล่าครูหญิงคะอ่ะ
วันนี้นะคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
สักครู่นะคะได้ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์นะและ
วันอาทิตย์
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15 ค่ะวันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมคุยเขียนในผู้หญิงต้องถามไม่ใช่
ค่ะดีผชอะไรคะมีผช
2551 อ่ะอ๋อ
กร่ปกติครูหญิงเขียนแล้วถาม
2565 นะคะปีคศอะไรคะ
ขาดพูดพ.ศ.อะไรคศเท่าไหร่
เท่าไหร่โอเคเนาะโอเคค่ะอ้าอะไรโอเคโอ๊ย
ตายค่ะครูเอ๋ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา
16:00 น
เลขสวยนะคะ
บาทไม่บาย 16:00 น 4 โมงเย็นแล้วไม่ร้อน
นะเย็นลายบายๆนี้เย็นแล้ว
คู๋ลบนะคะถ้าคู๋ลบลบๆผู้หญิงคะวันนี้
ครูเอ๋จะมีมี
คำถาม
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋มีคำถามถามครูหญิง
ชะช่าถามควีนคนเดียวไม่ถามนักเรียนไม่ถาม
นักเรียนมีแฟนนักเรียนคิดได้นายเวรในใจนะ
นักเรียนไม่ต้องพูดผู้หญิงพูดนะมีปากแล้ว
ก็พูดนักเรียนดูคิดเราก็ฟังค่ะอยู่ฟังคิด
อ่ะมึงไม่พูดมาค่ะครูเอ๋จะมีรูปค่ะค่ะให้
ครูหญิงดูแล้วไข่ค่ะถึงว่า
ถามอะไร
ตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นมีพิษหรือไม่มีพิษงูหมู
อะไรผิดไม่มีไม่เป็นไรไม่เข้าใจไม่เป็นไร
สวัสดีค่ะไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่เข้าใจเดี๋ยวดูแล้ว
ก็ฟังครูเอ๋กับครูหญิงเข้าหัวใจขอได้รับ
นักเรียน
สวัสดีไม่ได้สิคู๋
ต้อง 30 นาทีสวัสดีนะคะไม่ใช่ค่ะครูพูด
พูดนักเรียนไม่เข้าใจแล้วสวัสดีนักเรียน
บอกว่า
ขอโทษค่ะโอเคดูรูปที่ 1 ค่ะนักเรียนค่ะมา
ฆ่างูจะเป็นรูปอะไรนะ
ใหญ่พี่น่ากลัวมากเลยตัวเองมันใหญ่
วิ่งเห็นไหมอ่ะเห็นแล้วค่ะเห็นแล้วเห็น
แล้วยังทั้งหมดไหมคะเห็นทั้งหมดเลยค่ะ
โอเคค่ะอ่ะผู้หญิงคะในเรื่องนี้นะสีน้ำ
ตาลเนี่ยอาชื่อ
งูจงอาง
สีดำเนี่ยอ่ะผมชื่อ
ชื่องูอะไร
งูเห่าเอา
2 รูวิเป็นงูงู
ไม่เหมือนกันเอาไม่เหมือนกันสีน้ำตาล
งูจงอางค่ะสีดำ
งูเห่า
แล้วงู 2 ตัวมั้ยเหมือนกันแต่อาจจะมี
หนึ่งอย่างเหมือนเหมือนกันผู้หญิงคะคำถาม
งู
[เพลง]
จงอาง
กับกับงูเห่ามีพิษ
หรือไม่มีพิษคะ
รูหญิงคิดว่า
มีพิษค่ะอ่ะแต่ว่ามีพิษทะเลฮะอาหารมีพิษ
โอเคนักเรียนคิดว่างูจงอางกับงูเห่ามีพิษ
ไหมคะ
นักเรียนย่อถ้าคิดว่ามีพิษพยักหน้า
คิดว่าไม่มีพิษใส่หัวแล้วดูวีดีโอ
คอมเมนต์
[เพลง]
ครูหญิงคิดว่ามีพิษหรือไม่มีนะคะผู้หญิง
คิดว่ามีทิศฆ่าพ่อมีพิษโอเค
เฉลยพูดเฉลยมีพิษหรือไม่มีพิษคะ
มีพิษฆ่างูจงอางงูเห่ามีพิษงูจงอางมีพิษ
มากๆเอางูแล้วงูเห่า
เอาอ๋อ
คิดอยู่ที่ไหนคะครูหญิง
พิษอยู่
ที่ปากหวานเที่ยวหรอคะคุณเอ๋ถ้าใช่
[เพลง]
ขอเวลางูกัดค่ะกัดพิษก็จะเข้าไป
แล้วคุยถ้างูจงอางงูเห่ากับครูหญิงกับที่
ไหนแล้วก็กัดที่แขนอ๋ออ๋อกัดที่แขนก็ต้อง
มีอะไรนะกูยังไม่มีชื่ออาหารนี้ก็ได้อ่ะ
อุ้ยกัดตรงไหนกับที่นี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
กะทิแขนกับตรงนี้ก็ต้องหลังแขนสลัดอ๋อ
ก็เอาถ้าไม่รัดมันก็จะมีพิษแล้วมันก็จะ
วิ่งที่หัวใจผู้หญิงปายไหมคะบ๊ายบายตาย
ค่ะเฮ้ย
ตายแล้วอันนี้กว่าก็คือมีพิษคือใหม่ที่
ครูเอกพูดอ่ะใช่ใช่
งูมีพิษมากๆ
ตัว
ผู้หญิงมีอีกมีอีกหรอคะนักเรียนเข้าใจผิด
แล้วเนาะ
มีพิษพัดกัดแล้วตายสาขานี่ต่อไปค่ะครู
หญิงงูอีกเหมือนกัน
คู๋
อะไร
งูชื่ออะไรคะเนี่ยนหน้าไปที่ไหนผู้หญิง
ยังขาวไม่เห็นหน้าหยุดแต่พี่ขอ
โหย๋คืนนี้คุยอิ๋งนอนไม่โอเคแล้วเนี่ย
เห็นงูตัวนี้ถ้วยขอโทษนะคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
กลัวงูเหรอคะผู้หญิงไม่กลัวผิวเวลามันแบบ
มันนอนแล้วมันโคตรไปแล้วเออคนลูกโอเคอ่า
กันตอบเร็วๆแล้วไปใครงูตัวนี้ชื่องู
เหลือม
งูเหลือมอ่ะผู้หญิงครั้งงูเหลือมมีทิศ
หรือไม่มีพิษครูหญิงคิดว่าไม่มีทิศ
เก่งมากๆเหลืองไม่มีพิษนะคะถ้างั้นงู
เหลือมกัดครูหญิงผู้หญิงไม่ตายเพราะงู
เหลือมกัดเนี่ยไม่มีพิษแต่บางทีมี
แบคทีเรียมีไวรัสมีสไตล์เหมือนกัน
ไม่มีพิษแต่มีแบคทีเรียมีไวรัสราคาหัว
เห็นชอบงูเหลือมไหมคะไม่ชอบตัวเอไม่ชอบงู
คลิปนี้นะครูเอ๋ดูภาพ
เอกก็นอนทาบสัตว์ที่มีพิษครูเอก
น่ากลัวไม่เอาไม่เอาไม่เอางูโอเค
ต่อไปต่อไปดีป่าวบ๊ายบายงูไม่ชอบ
ลิงเหรอคะครูเอ๋ถ้ายังค่ะจะถามว่ากูหญิง
รู้จักไหมอะไรจริงค่ะลิงผู้หญิงลิงมีพิษ
ไหมคะ
มีพิษมายัง
ไม่มีอ๋อ
แต่ถ้าไม่คะถ้าลิงกัดก็ตายนะคะตัวลิงกัด
ลิงมีไวรัสไวรัสไม่ใช่พิษอ๋อไวรัสไม่ใช่
พิษนะคะ
I  might ดีมาก
เก่งมั้ง
[เพลง]
ลิงไม่มีพิษค่ะใช่ไหมคะแต่ลิงมีไวรัสนะคะ
ฉะนั้นลิเวก็ต้องล้างค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบลิง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เมื่อก่อนชอบลิงตอนนี้ไม่ชอบ
ลิงกัดแขนครูเอ๋เห่นะคะไปไวรัสเลเวลสูง
ครูหญิงคู๋จะมี Story ลิงกลับนะค่ะได้ค่ะ
ตัวต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไรอีกคะตัวต่อไปนี้
ไอ้ตัวนี้กูก็รู้ไหมคะชื่ออะไร
ชื่อ
แมงป่องช้างใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเก่งมากมาหาที่
บ้านมีผู้หญิงอันนี้นี่เองไม่รู้แมงป่อง
ช้างนี้ผิดไหมเนื่องกล่องช้างหรอมีสิ
นี่นะมีพิษมีพิษที่หางใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ใช่
ค่ะ
แมงป่องมีพิษแต่อาจจะมีพิษนิดหน่อยเนาะ
ไม่มีพิษที่หางทรายมีพิษนิดหน่อย
นะคะไม่มากๆมาหากินใหม่มากมายครับแต่บี
ทิศนะคะดูผิด Doo  Doo หาเนี่ยตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมแหลมเนี่ยมันจะมันปล่อยน้องเรียกว่า
ต๋อยจะต่อยอีก
ต่อไป
มีอีกไหมคะมีหัด
อะไรคะครูเองปลาหรอปลาค่ะ
น้ำก่อนนะครับได้ค่ะผู้เอกท่านได้ไหมฝัน
ที่คอยพูดมากๆ
ครูเอ๋ปลาอะไรคะปลาปักเป้าค่ะ
ปลาปาเป้า
ปาเป้า
คนคนญี่ปุ่นน่ะ
จะมีคนใช่ไหมแต่เป็นคนประเทศญี่ปุ่น
กินหอ
คำถามค่าเป้ามีผิดไหมคะค่ะ
มีไม่มีไม่มีเอ้าท์ทำไมคุณ
ครูเอ๋บอกคนญี่ปุ่นกินอ๋อมีพิษคนญี่ปุ่น
กินก็
ตาย
เหอะๆไม่มีผิดผู้หญิงคิดไม่มีพิษไม่มี
ถูกไหมคะ
คนญี่ปุ่นกินปลาปั๊กเป้าที่มีพิษไม่ตาย
อ๋อ
ไม่รู้อะไรอะไรก็ครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงก่อนผู้
หญิงก่อนเฮ้ยพี่จะบอกว่าอ่อหรือว่าปลา
เป้าเนี่ยมีพิษที่หางคนญี่ปุ่นไม่กินหาง
ก็ไม่ตายไม่ใช่มีพิษที่หนองเนี่ยหนังแม่
เอาที่หลังอ่ะผิดที่ไหนคะก็มีเพียงนั้น
เหรอหนังใช่ไหมคะ
มันก็ไม่น่าอร่อยเนาะอร่อยครูๆคุยอร่อย
ลืม
ป่าวเนี่ยอ่ะมีมีแบบมีผิดนิดหน่อยมีพิษ
มากๆ
แบบนี้มีพิษนิดหน่อยกินได้
รีบพิษมากๆกินไม่ได้
ได้ๆๆ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงบอกก็มีผิดนิดหน่อย
กินได้แป้งผู้หญิง
ไม่ได้เรียนไม่ได้เรียนทำซาชิมิเอาผู้
หญิงมาหั่นๆ
กินกะไม่ได้ออกแปลว่าต้องมีเทคนิคเทคนิค
หั่นปลาปักเป้าดูยังไงเราก็กินก็ได้แล้ว
ก็ต้องมีเช็คหนิกเอาคลิปออกไปโอไม่ต้อง
เก่งเหรอใช่กูเอกก็ไม่รู้ผิดที่ไหนบ้าง
รู้แต่ว่าที่หนังที่หลัง
ที่หลังปลามีพิษก็ต้องเอาออกไปค่ะแล้วก็
พิษไม่มีในเนื้อกินโอเคค่ะทั้งแท้มากกู
เอกบอกอร่อยครูเอกเคยกินหรอคะอ้าไม่เคย
กิน
คุยไม่กินซะชิมิอะ
เนื้อเพลงเสวันนี้ปลาตัวนี้ปลาอะไรคะปลา
สิงโต
วงปลาสิงโตค่ะครูหญิงปลาสิงโตมีพิษไหมคะ
อาร์สิงโตมีพิษไหมคะไม่มีค่ะทำไมคิดว่า
ไม่มีคิดเอาสวยยไม่มีพิษหรือว่าสวยมีพิษ
จริงคิดพิษไม่มีไปนี้หรอมี
แอด
ปลาสิงโตมีพิษที่ไหนมีพิษมีพิษที่นี่ตรง
ไหนคะตรงครีบนะค่ะแข็งๆน่ะหรอมีพิษจริงๆ
น่าจะมีแถวนี้ด้วยถ้าเนี่ยถ้าครูหญิงจับ
ปลาสิงโต
มันแพงผิดจะเข้าไปเอา
น้ำเพลงกูอันนี้ที่ทะเลถ้าครูหญิงจับแล้ว
ปุ๊ปคุย
ตายเลยเหรอคะครูเอ๋จมน้ำจมอออะไรน้ำไม่
ได้ก็
ตายให้นะคะสวยดูโอเคไม่จับนะคะมีกินนะคะ 3
มีทิศน่ากลัวมีพิษที่ครีบนะคะค่ะต่อไปมี
อีกไหมคะครูเอ๋มีค่า
อะไรครับผู้หญิงแมลงสาบแมลงสาบมีพิษแมง
สาบแมลงสาบไม่มีพิษค่ะมีพิษไหม
เก่งมากไม่มีค่ะไม่มีพิษเย้ดีใจจะแบะจับ
ใช่ไหมคะ
จับได้แต่เหม็น
ไม่มีพิษแต่
ไม่มีพิษมีไวรัสมีแบคทีเรียน่าจะมี
แบคทีเรียมากๆนะคะครูเองใช่งั้นไม่มีพิษ
นะคะแต่จับไม่โอเคไม่ดีนี่ไม่ดีกลับไปค่ะ
ผู้หญิง
ตัวอะไรคะรู้เองแมลงวันค่ะแมลงวัน
ครูหญิงแมลงวันมีพิษไหมคะ
ไม่มีพิษค่ะครูเอ๋
ถูกไหมคะค่ะ
เก่งมากค่ะงูแมลงวันไม่มีพิษมีว่าดูนะมี
แบคทีเรียนักเรียนออกไวรัสแบตไม่มีพิษไม่
มีพิษและไม่มีพิษค่ะต่อไป
ตัวอะไรรู้ไหมเพลงแมงมุมเหรอคะตายเลยค่ะ
อุ้ยมีชื่อมั้ยคุย
ชื่อแมงมุมแม่ม่ายดำ
โหแมงมุมแม่ม่ายดำ
ผู้หญิงแมงมุมแม่ม่ายดำมีพิษหรือไม่มีพิษ
ครูหญิงคิดว่ามีพิษค่ะ
ทำไมคู่หญิงคิดว่ามีพิษผู้หญิงดูแล้วคิด
อ่ะน่ากลัวอา
ก็เลยคิดว่ามีพิษไทยค่ะครูเบลอเอ๋อยมีพิษ
ไหมคะ
มีพิษค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเก่งมาก
สีแดงเนาะก้นที่จูนผิดอยู่ตรงไหนอาคูโอะ
โอ๋เอ๋อออน่าจะกลับล่ะค่ะเวลาก๊อดอยู่ที่
เที่ยวน้องน่าจะหมายเหมือนเหี่ยวกับแล้ว
ก็ผิดเข้าไงหากลูนโอเค
อะไรตัวอะไรคะครูเอ๋
มดค่ะหมดนะมีมากๆหมดตัวนี้ชื่อมดตะนอย
ตาน้อยอุ๊ยให้
รู้จักไหมรู้จักค่ะตัวเองผู้หญิงมดตะนอย
มีพิษไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามี
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เฉลย
มีไหมคะมีค่ะมดตะนอยมีพิษนะคะพุ่งมีพิษ
คิดของมดตาน้อยมดตะนอยพี่อยู่ตรงไหนคะเขา
บอกว่าอยู่ที่ก้นน่ะน้องปิ่นก็ว่างั้น
แหละเวลามันมันทอนน่ะมันคันและแสบตาๆ
แล้วมันก็กลับคิดเป็นก็มานะเวลากาดหรอ
กลับหมดก็น้อยมันต่อยใช่ไหม
มันต่อยกัดกัดด้วยต่อยด้วยแบบด่วน 1 ใจ
แต่ว่ามันน่ากลัวนะคะครูเอ๋ใช่ๆนะกลัวนัก
เรียน
มดตะนอยพิษ Maybe กี๊ดมีอีกไหมคะมีมียัง
มีเวลาใช่ไหมคะยังมีเวลาค่ะครูเอ๋คู่
คิงส์
ครึ่งมีพิษหรือไม่มีคิดค่ะง่ายๆค่ะคู๋มี
คิดมี th มีผิดผิดอยู่ที่ไหนพิษอยู่ถ้า
พี่
คุยวันที่
สีเหลืองอีกอะไร
พิษอยู่ที่อัดใส่ข่าพิษอยู่ที่ก้นผะครู
เอ๋ผิดอยู่ที่ก้นนะคะเพราะถูกไหมคะถูกค่ะ
ไม่ได้กัดแต่ต่อยนะต่อยต่อยโอ๊ยตายเจ็บนะ
คะบางคนไม่สบายนะคะมีพิษให้
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิง
โอ๊ยโอ๊ยอันไหนคะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋ถามอะไรโอเค
ถามอันนี้
อ้าวอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋
ดอกไม้ทะเล
งุ้มทะเลใช่ไหมคะรักอยู่ในทะเล
ทะเลฮาวายทะเล
น้ำทะเลก็มีดอกไม้ใต้ทะเลชื่อดอกไม้ทะเล
ผู้หญิงคะดอกไม้ทะเลมีพริบไหมคะไม่มีทิศ
ค่ะ
หือข้างใหม่คิดไม่มีพิษตรงนี้คะมีปลาว่าย
น้ำอยู่ใกล้ๆกลาไม่ตายจะไม่มีพิษถูกไหมคะ
ผิดค่ะอ้าวดอกไม้ทะเลมีพิษเหรอคะครูเอ๋
ดอกไม้ทะเลมีคลิปแต่ปลาการ์ตูนตัวนี้ชื่อ
ปลาการ์ตูนปลาการ์ตูนที่ผิวมีมีอะไรไม่
รู้มีใครๆฟรีเป็นเมื่ออยู่ที่นี่เวลาเข้า
ไปดอกไม้ทะเลเอา
นี่ปลาการ์ตูนไม่ได้
ออนแต่ถ้าครูหญิงจับดอกไม้ทะเลคิดก็โดน
ครูหญิงเอาภาพปลาไม่ใช่ปลาการ์ตูนเข้าไป
ดอกไม้ทะเลก็ใส่พิษแล้วปลาก็ตายดอกไม้
ทะเลก็กิน
ดอกไม้ทะเลเป็นเอเลี่ยนเหรอกู xxx
ป้าเล็กๆกิน
คู่เอกคะอันนี้ก็คือพิษพี่จุดตรงนี้ของ
เขาเลยเหรอคะมันเลยผิดผิดไปอยู่แถวนี้อ่ะ
อ๋อผู้หญิงกลับกับผิดน่ะนิดหน่อยนะนิด
หน่อยถ้าเป็นคนก็จะคันอ๋อเพราะคนแต่ตัว
ใหญ่ชายตัวใหญ่มาจากคันคู๋เคยจับไม่เป็น
ไรน้องผู้เห็นเหมือนปลาการ์ตูนเหรอคะถ้า
มีเมื่อ
มีแต่เพื่อนครูเอกจับคำเอ่อโดนพิษได้ไหม
ค่ะดอกไม้ทะเลมีพิษนะคะนักเรียนมีพิษมี
อีกไหมคะครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงอะไรคะไม่รู้จักหอยเต้าปูน
พี่เอ๋คะอะไรคะอ่าทั้งหมดอันนี้หรอคือหอย
ใช่อ๋อ
เห็นไหมครับเห็น
หอยเต้าปูน
ข่อยชื่อเตาปูนพูดข่อยเตาปูนผู้หญิงหอย
เต้าปูนมีพิษไหมคะ
อันนี้คือหญิงไม่รู้ได้ไม่รู้จริงๆเหมือน
ยาสิงห์แก้วเลยอ่ะนะคะมีแค่มีพิษไม่มีพิษ
เองผู้หญิงคิดว่าว่ามีพิษอ้าวไม่รู้ทำไม
คิดมีพิษ
do
you น่ากลัวอ๋อ
อ๋อผู้หญิงเดาใช่ไหมคะเดาค่ะเพราะว่าผู้
หญิงไม่รู้ก็ 50  50 มีพิษไม่มีพิษก็คิด
ถึงมีพิษ
ถ้ามีพิษไม่มีพิษที่ไหมคะ
โอเคค่ะเฉลยค่ะผู้หญิงคิดไหมคะมีพิษมาก
ค่ะ
พี่หมอจริงกูอย่างนี้กินผิดแถวๆเนี่ยกู
เองไม่เธอก็น่าจะแถวเนี่ยเธอคุยก็คิดได้
มีผิดก็จะคิดตรงนั้นแล้วค่ะดูมันน่ากลัว
มีเพียงมากผู้หญิงผู้หญิงจับนะแล้วก็มีมี
พิษออกมา
ผู้หญิงเดิน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9
ๆ
ใช่ครูเอ๋เอ๋มากคุยคะหอยเต้าปูนอนิดตัว
ใหญ่หรือว่าตัวเล็กเล็กๆ
เล็กทำไมสวยแต่มีพิษผู้เหวตั้ง gui ให้
ผู้หญิงดูมาเนี่ยสวยมีพิษเล็กๆมีพิษวินาศ
ส่วนนะคะน่ากลัวนะคะจะไปค่ะครูหญิงมีเวลา
มาอีกนะเวลามีเวลาได้อีกค่ะอุ้ย
อะไรคะครูเอ๋หอยมือเสือ
ไหนหอยปะ
เนี่ยหอยมึงอ่ะ
ผู้ใหญ่ชาติ 5 หอยมีเสือมือมือเฮ้ยสีมือ
เสืออ่ะมีพิษไหมคะผู้หญิงขออันนี้ไหมสวย
รวยใหญ่ไม่มีพิษค่ะ
ถูกค่ะไม่มีพิษนะคะ
หรอกินได้มั้ยคะ
หอยมือเสือบางคนกินงั้นบางคนกินครูเอ๋ไม่
กินนะคะหอยมือเสือบางทีตัวใหญ่นี่ใหญ่
เท่านี้เลยนะผู้หญิงกูใหญ่มากเข้า
คอมพิวเตอร์ได้
ใช่ๆบางทีใหญ่กว่าก็มีสระใหญ่มานะคะต่อไป
คู่หญิงค่ะอุ้ยอยู่นี่
ไม่น่าถามแล้วนะแม่นทะเลๆ
บ่แม่นทะเลค่ะมีพิษไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงเมี่ยวยังไม่รู้ว่ามันมีพิษไหมอ่ะ
อ่ะเอาคิดนะผิดเฉยๆพี่พิษอ่ะ
ไม่มีมีไม่มี
หางเพราะว่าไม่มีมันได้ใช่ไหม
ว่าต้องสีส้มอันนี้กินได้นะคะผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงปาเป้าก็กินได้มีเพอชั่นคุณญี่ปุ่น
ทำไมชอบกินอะไรมีพิษค่ะ
เม่นทะเลกินได้มีพิษไหมคะผู้หญิงบอกว่า
ไม่มีขอเฉลยค่ะไม่มีค่ะเย้เก่งมากๆเม่น
ทะเลมีหนามแบบนี้ค่ะงั้นสีดำสำหรับหน้า
เนี่ยน้ำเนี่ยพาดเราต่ำชนะแต่ถ้าเราเดิน
เดินแล้วมันเหยียบใช่ไหมเหยียบเนี่ยมี
เท้า
มันตั้มเนี่ย
เจ็บแล้วไม่มีพิษไม่มีพิษวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
วิ่งๆไม่มีไม่มีแต่เจ็บโอ๊ยที่จะบัวเจ็บ
นะฮะมิอีกมีอีกผู้หญิงมีอีกอายุอีกก็ได้
นะเดี๋ยวมีเวลายังมีเวลาแม็กซ์แมงกระพุน
มีพิษไหมค่ะแมงกะพรุนอะไรคะแม่ก็พูด
ง่ายไงแมงกระพรุนมีชื่อไหมก็ชื่อแมง
กระพุนอ้าวหรอ
ไม่มีค่ะเพราะว่าชื่อแมงกะพรุนไม่มี
ชื่อต้องกด
คู๋เรื่องแรงเรียกแมงกระพรุนเฉยๆผู้หญิง
เรียกมี
แมงกะพรุน
แมงกะพรุนผู้หญิงคิดว่าไม่มีพิษใช่ไหมไม่
มีพิษฆ่าอร่อยอร่อยใช่ไหม
เฉลยมีผิดไหมคะแอดมีพี่มีพิษค่ะแต่มีแมง
กระพรุนอันนี้มีผิดนิดหน่อยมีพิษตรงไหน
อ่ะครูเอ๋มันมีนะมันมี
มีเพียงเรากินได้นิดหน่อยอ๋อต้องมีเทคนิค
แท็กครูหญิงคลิปโอ้แมงกะพรุนกินได้จับมา
แล้วก็กินน่ากลัวอา
แต่ก็ไม่คิดแมงกะพรุนอันนี้มีผิดนิดหน่อย
นิดหน่อยต้องมีเทคนิคทำเหมือนปลาเป้าชาย
ก็ต้องมีเทคนิคแต่ปลาปักเป้ามีพิษมากกว่า
นะคะอันนี้มีนิดนี้นะคะถึงนิดเดียวแปลต่อ
ไปแมงกระพรุนไฟ
มีพิษค่ะแม่ไม่ให้ถามเหรอคะโอเคถามก็ได้
ตอบแล้วก็จะมีพิษวิกะมีพิษค่ะ
ปิงปองเทมีอันนี้มีพิษมีพิษมากๆมีที่ตรง
ไหนครูเอ๋ราคาทั้งหมดน่ะอ๋อ
น่ากลัวจังเลยเนี่ยกะมีพิษขึ้นอ่ะทำไมสวย
นี่น่ากลัวนะวันนี้น่ากลัวนะทาบ
แขนจะบวมบวมซื้อนะถ้าอย่างนั้นแมงแมง
กะพรุนไฟก็มีพิษมากๆมีพิษมีผิดค่ะถ้าโดน
ตัวจะทำให้เนื้อ
งดเลยเหรอคะมันเจ็บมัน
ฮะโอเคมีเลยอ่ะ
กับอะๆๆอันนี้อีกนิดนึงได้ไหมคะผู้หญิง
ใต้ค่ะได้ค่ะตัวเองผู้หญิงเห็ดอันเนี้ยกู
เองไม่รู้ชื่ออะไรมีพิษไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีพิษค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไมคิดว่ามี
พิษผึ้งสวย
เก่งว่ามากนักเรียนคะผ้าเหตุสวยนะมีพิษนะ
คะแต่ถ้าแบบนี้มีพิษไม่หาไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
ผิดนะคะอ่ะก็ยังมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหม
มีอะไรหรอ
เวมีมีดอกไม้
ดอกกูละดอกกุหลาบมีพิษไหมคะ
ไม่มีอ๋ออ๋อไม่มีโอเคนึกว่ามีพิษตกใจเลย
นี่ไม่มีไม่มี
อีดอกลำโพงมีผิดไหมคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าไม่มี
คือแอบ
มีพิษเหรอคู๋ได้ดอกลำโพงมีพิษมีดอกไม้ก็
มีพิษใช่มีบางอย่างมีพิษนะคะมีนี้
โอเค
เท่าไหร่เองหมามุ่ย
หมามุ่ย
หมามุ่ยมีพิษไหมคะ
เราโดนแล้วเราก็คันเนาะใช่
น้องเป็นพิษไหมอ่ะกูบอกว่าคิดว่ามีพิษ
แล้วกันค่ะครูเอ๋
ต้องเอามันเป็นพิษของมันเหรอคะเวลาเราโดน
แล้วคันใช้ค่ะหมามุ่ยถ้าโดนแล้วคันเนี่ย
ก็เรียนเป็นคลิป
หมามุ่ยคงโค้งใช่ไหมคะ
อันสุดท้ายน้องหมดเวลาแล้วก็เพราะผู้หญิง
มะขามมีพิษไหมคะทำไม่ดีก็กันดีมามุ่ยดู
แล้วเหมือนๆมะขามนะ
ยังผู้หญิงกินมะขามอ้ากหรอไม่พอออกไม่มี
ผิดใช่เลยค่ะมีไหมคะครูเอ๋ไม่มี
ตกใจเลยตกใจนะคะหากวันนี้นักเรียนนะคะนัก
เรียนก็รู้จักมีพิษหรือไม่มีพิษนะคะงูมี
พิษปลาปักเป้ามีพิษนะคะใส่ค่ะครูหญิงกับ
ครูเอ๋ไม่มีพิษไม่มีผิดนะคะ
โอเคค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้ครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋ไป
ก่อนนะคะอะแล้วเจอกันใหม่เนาะค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย
ม.ค